bienvenidos de nuevo en el vídeo pasado
nos quedamos resolviendo el problema 13
pero déjame empezarlo de nuevo para que
no sea tan confuso resolver un mismo
problema en el transcurso de dos vídeos
distintos así que tenemos el problema
número 13 y que es el problema número 13
que teníamos una secuencia de números la
cual era 3 después seguía el 5 después
seguía el menos 5 y así seguía y seguía
y seguía y seguía pero además déjame
contarte que habíamos dicho que esta
secuencia de números empezaba en el 3 y
cada término par era el término anterior
más 2 y cada término el par era el
término anterior por menos 1 así que
déjame hacer aquí una tabla para que
veamos qué pasa con los primeros
términos de esta sucesión terminó
después voy a poner el valor del término
el valor y aquí voy a poner
efe de x es decir que le estamos
haciendo a este término y déjame trazar
aquí
líneas de mi tabla y ahora sí para
entender mejor esta secuencia de números
vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa en cada
uno de estos términos en el primer
término mi primer término si te das
cuenta es 3 entonces tiene como valor 3
y como es mi término inicial nfl x lo
voy a dejar vacío porque no le hicimos
nada ahora nuestro siguiente término es
el número 2 y como su término par hay
que agarrar al valor anterior ya este
valor sumarle 2 pues recuerda que cada
uno de los términos pares nos vamos a
encontrar sumándole 2 a nuestro
resultado anterior y 3 más dos es 5 y
por eso me da de valor 5 ahora nuestro
siguiente términos el término número 3
pero el número 3 es un término impar y
para resolver este término en paz lo que
hay que hacer es tomar el término
anterior es decir el 5 este de aquí y
vamos a multiplicarlo por menos 1 es lo
que me dice mi regla 5 x menos 1 y 5 x
menos 1 es menos 5 entonces el valor del
término 3
-5 muy bien ahora qué pasaría con el
término 4 como es un término impar
entonces lo que hay que hacer es
tomarnos el término anterior que era
menos 5 ya esto sumarle 2 porque cada
uno de los términos pares hay que
sumarle 2 al término anterior y menos
cinco más dos es menos 3 por lo tanto el
valor del término 4 es menos 3 y ahora
si nos fijamos en el valor del término 5
pues es el valor de un término impar por
lo tanto nos tenemos que agarrar el
término anterior que es menos 3 ya esto
multiplicarlo por menos 1 recuerda que a
cualquier término impar hay que
multiplicarlo por menos 1 por lo tanto
menos 3 por menos 1 estrés positivo y
ahora sí entonces voy a poner que el
valor de mi término 5 estrés y aquí ya
puedes empezar a ver el patrón porque
nuestro término 6 va a ser un término
par y por lo tanto hay que tomarnos al
término anterior que es 3 y entonces hay
que sumarle 2
y entonces le sumamos 2 y me queda que
325 y otra vez estamos regresando a este
valor al 5 y si yo me agarro después el
de menos 7 que crees que le va a pasar
pues es un término en par por lo tanto
habría que tomarme el 5 anterior
entonces vamos a ponerlo aquí y
multiplicando por menos 1 entonces lo
voy a multiplicar por menos 1 porque
estamos hablando de un término impar y
me da el menos 5 que tengo aquí arriba
el término 7 es igual a menos 5 y yo
agarro el término 8 el término 8
entonces lo que tendría que hacer es a
este menos 5 sumarle 2 y esto me va a
dar menos 3 y entonces aquí me daría
menos 3 y si yo pongo el término 9 el
término 9 va a ser ya divida el término
9 mi valor va a ser 3
es decir se está repitiendo otra vez
esta secuencia estamos encontrando un
ciclo 35 menos 5 menos 335 menos 5 menos
3 y bueno todo esto lo puedes
experimentar por ti mismo lo importante
es que hagas muchos términos
encuentres este ciclo justo así es como
funciona esta secuencia esa es la clave
si por ejemplo en una de las preguntas
del sat nos preguntan cuál es el término
100 entonces debe haber un ciclo o una
fórmula porque los creadores del libro
no esperan que nos pongamos escribir 100
términos porque nos tardaríamos una
eternidad y bueno en este caso date
cuenta que tenemos un ciclo de 435 mil
523 este sería nuestro primer ciclo 3
553 aquí tenemos otro ciclo y así nos
seguimos y nos seguimos y nos seguimos y
bueno lo que nos preguntan es cuánto
vale el término 55 de esta secuencia
ahora para esto quiero que te des cuenta
que cada término que es múltiplo de 4
su valor es menos 3 el valor del término
4 es igual a menos 3 el valor del
término 8 que también es múltiplo de 4
es igual a menos 3 y si no seguimos en
esta secuencia y nos fijamos en el
término 12 su valor
es menos 3 tú no puedes creerlo lo
puedes verificar por ti mismo entonces
cada término que es múltiplo de 4
su valor es menos 3 así que vamos a
buscar el término múltiplo de 4 más
cercanos 55 que de hecho creo que es el
término 56 56 que es divisible entre 4
56 entre 4 cabe y es 14 veces entonces
el término 56 su valor va a ser menos 3
porque es un término que es múltiplo de
4 y bueno si el término 56 su valor es
menos 3 el término 55 cuál va a ser su
valor pues si nosotros nos fijamos en el
valor del término anterior siempre es
menos 5 aquí es menos 5 aquí es menos 5
también entonces el término anterior al
término 56 es decir mi término 55 su
valor va a ser menos 5 justo esta es mi
respuesta correcta que por cierto era el
inciso a
así que ya hemos resuelto este problema
y vamos a movernos al siguiente problema
así que déjenme borrar esta pantalla y
ahora sí vamos a resolver nuestro
problema 14
muy bien el problema 14 dice así si la
recta l la recta l tiene como ecuación
la ecuación que es igual a 2 x + 5 y la
recta m es la reflexión de la recta l en
el eje x cuál es la ecuación de la recta
m y bueno lo que voy a hacer es dibujar
la recta l pero esto no lo tienen que
hacer forzosamente en su problema si
ustedes saben la respuesta la puede
escribir sin graficar las dos rectas así
que vamos a dibujar dos ejes en mi recta
el éxito fijas tiene una ordenada al
origen de 5 es decir corta el eje de las
10 en el valor de 5 voy a suponer que es
este valor además tiene una pendiente de
2 por lo tanto mi recta l se ve más o
menos
algo así y dice que mi recta m es la
reflexión de la recta l en el eje de las
equis y bueno como este es el eje de las
equis y si vemos la recta reflejada no
sé supongamos en una alberca de agua
entonces la reflexión se va a ver como
si tomamos esta recta y le damos un giro
o le damos una vuelta alrededor del eje
de las equis así que la recta m se va a
ver más o menos así esta sería mi recta
m y así que dos cosas es como si fuera
el eje x un espejo y por lo tanto se ve
al revés o de otra manera lo que estamos
haciendo es dándole una vuelta a la
recta l alrededor del eje de las equis y
lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta
es que si la recta en le corta el eje de
las 10 en 5 la recta en nueva portada le
genera 10 en menos 5 por lo tanto
ordenada al origen de la recta ms 5 y lo
segundo que quiero que te des cuenta es
que la recta m va a tener la misma
pendiente que la recta l pero negativa
si la recta l tenía una pendiente de 2
es decir por cada uno que caminemos en
el eje hace x vamos a subir 2 entonces
mi recta l va a tener una pendiente de
menos 2 por cada uno que caminemos en el
eje de las x vamos a bajar 2 en el eje
de las 10 es decir la pendiente de m es
igual a menos 2 y entonces ya que
tenemos su pendiente sobre nada de
origen
podemos decir que m tiene la ecuación 10
es igual a menos dos bases su pendiente
por x menos 5 corta en el eje de la
siesta es menos 5 y además tenemos una
pendiente de menos 2 y ahora si nos
fijamos en las respuestas del libro
también es el inciso a y bueno como ya
estoy corriendo en tiempo vamos a ver
los siguientes problemas en el siguiente
vídeo